clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi ça lui revient ça va
ouais nickel à jawad a même pas un petit
truc à me demandais je sais pas te que
d'habitude comme on en rêve spécial chez
en pleine forme mais deborah par les
grands trous du coup je sais pas cech
tes mails et peut-être des gens qui ont
des trucs elle tira d'adaptateurs alors
oui mais comment tuer ouais on va faire
ça
il ya quelques temps je vous ai proposé
de me poser des questions concernant
votre santé et concernant des faits le
moment est venu d'y répondre
alors avant de commencer un truc que
j'avais pas précisé mais j'aurais dû
évidemment tous restent anonymes
sachez le pour la prochaine fois oui
parce que comme j'ai reçu énormément de
questions je pense que je referai ce
genre de vidéos à l'avenir donc vous
pouvez continuer à en envoyer
juste un petit truc pratique si vous
pouvez mettre le sujet dont vous voulez
parler dans l'objet du mail c'est plus
facile pour moi pour me retrouver après
un bon s'échiner tandis c'est parti la
consultation
donc on commence par vos questions perso
encore une fois je suis infirmier pas
médecin donc je vais vous donner des
pistes mais pas de diagnostic et pas de
traitement apprendre par exemple a
laissé là est ce qu'un grain de beauté
qui apparaît sur le corps sur le visage
dans mon cas du jour au lendemain est
susceptible d'être dangereux alors
évidemment je peux pas te dire comme ça
si ton grain de beauté il est dangereux
par contre je peux aider à déterminer si
ça vaut la peine d'aller le montrer un
dermato pour ça il suffit d'appliquer la
règle a b c d e rapport à l'alphabet
c'est à dire est ce que ton grain de
beauté et asymétrique est ce qu il a une
forme pas vraiment arrondi est-ce qu'il
a des bords irréguliers
est-ce que les contours sont pas très
net ou genre un peu dans clé est-ce
qu'il a plusieurs couleurs est-ce que
son diamètre est supérieur à 6 mm ou
est-ce qu'il avait augmenté
est-ce qu'il a une évolution rapide
genre est-ce qu'il a beaucoup changé
d'aspect dans ton cas a priori tu peux
répondre oui au mois aux deux dernières
questions donc mon conseil va le montrer
la dermato globalement pour tout le
monde
l'idéal c'est d'aller chez le dermato au
moins une fois par an pour faire
contrôler ces grains de beauté
je me demandais si c'était possible de
tomber enceinte pendant les règles sans
prendre de moyens contraceptifs alors à
priori pour que ça match dans le grand
hinder de l'utérus pour qu'ils aient une
fécondation pour servir pour tomber
enceinte
le meilleur moment c'est le moment de
l'ovulation c'est à dire en plein milieu
du cycle c'est à dire pile entre le
début des dernières règles et le début
des suivantes
en gros au 14e jour du cycle vu qu'en
moyenne ainsi que ça dure 28 jours et le
pire moment celui où il ya le moins de
chances que ça arrive c'est pendant les
règles
théoriquement parce que vous savez ça
mieux que moi c'est pas si régulier que
ça hein c'est pas du papier à musique
il peut y avoir plein de trucs qui
perturbe un petit peu le cycle il peut y
avoir aussi des saignements qui sont pas
vraiment des règles donc c'est trompeur
mais bref
retenez juste un truc dans l'absolu
c'est très rare mais oui on peut tomber
enceinte après un rapport sexuel pendant
les règles du coup le mieux c'est
d'avoir un moyen de contraception
efficace tout le temps sans parler de se
protéger contre les infections
sexuellement transmissibles
je vous remets le lien vers la vidéo
passage vous y retourne je me suis fait
opérer d'une tumeur au sein en 2010 est
depuis j'ai quelques douleurs et une
grosse cicatrice mais je n'ai jamais
posé la question aux médecins qui m'ont
pris en charge est-ce que je vais avoir
des problèmes pour allaiter plus tard
est aussi petit bonus
est ce que c'est normal d'avoir encore
mal après deux ans pour répondre à la
première question
faudrait savoir quel genre d'opération
tu as eu exactement
donc c'est compliqué après une opération
pour un cancer du sein parfois c'est
possible d'arrêter avec le salon père et
parfois non mais par contre ils restent
toujours l'autre c'est évidemment en ce
qui concerne la douleur ça peut être lié
à la cicatrice elle même
ça peut adhérer aux tissus à l'intérieur
et tirer un petit peu voire beaucoup ça
peut aussi être un autre type de
douleurs liées aux nerfs qui ont été
touchés pendant l'opération
bon mais la question c'est est est ce
que c'est normal d'avoir mal vision que
c'est des choses qui arrivent c'est des
choses qui arrivent même assez
régulièrement mais ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il faut rien faire
il ya des traitements pour que ça
s'arrête mais le seul moyen de trouver
celui qui sera efficace pour toi c'est
de trouver la cause donc d'en parler au
médecin j'ai un prépuce légèrement trop
petit je peux donc décalotter de
justesse au repos mais pas du tout en
érection est ce que tu peux me dire si
ça en fait un réel problème ou juste une
caractéristique négligeable alors
manifestement tu as un phimosis
c'est-à-dire un rétrécissement du
prépuce la peau qui
autour le blanc c'est hyper fréquents
chez les enfants généralement ça passe
en grandissant mais pas toujours si ça
te pose problème genre si ça te gêne ou
si ça te fait mal pendant les rapports
sexuels par exemple parlez-en à un
médecin
il ya des solutions passé un certain âge
c'est souvent une petite opération genre
une circoncision ou autre chose et on
rentre chez soi le soir même pourquoi on
a envie de faire caca après avoir bu du
café
alors j'ai déjà répondu à cette question
en vidéo donc je vous la remet un petit
coup la vidéo et j'y réponds aussi dans
mon bouquin ainsi qu'à pleurent d'autres
questions hyper intéressante sur cette
merveilleuse matière et qui sait puisque
six états tiers
donc n'hésitez pas c'est bientôt noël
vous avez aussi été pas mal à me poser
des questions sur les psychothérapies
qu'ils allaient voir dans quels cas etc
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de s'y
retrouver et ça mérite vraiment une
vidéo complète sur le sujet mais en
attendant je vais quand même vous donner
un ou deux petits trucs pour s'y
retrouver
il ya des tas de métiers dont le nom
commence par ci et pour lesquels n'y a
pas forcément de réglementation comme
psychanalyste par exemple ou
psychothérapeute ça ça veut juste dire
quelqu'un qui soigne les troubles
psychologiques
donc c'est pas très clair on sait pas
forcément à qui on a affaire
ça peut être un petit peu compliqué du
coup au début si vous savez pas trop qui
allait voir
dirigez-vous vers un ou une psychologue
ou un ou une psychiatre la grosse
différence entre les deux c'est que le
deuxième
le psychiatre c'est un médecin donc
c'est quelqu'un qui peut poser un
diagnostic médical et qui peut prescrire
des médicaments
si besoin pas forcément mais si besoin
mais les deux peuvent vous suivre et
vous aider sur le plan psychologique
après ça dépend de la raison qui vous
pousse à consulter mais disons dans un
premier temps c'est peut-être pas mal
d'aller voir un médecin
donc un psychiatre qui éventuellement
dans un deuxième temps vous dira qu'ils
allaient voir de préférence pour le
suivi le truc c'est que c'est souvent
très longs d'avoir un rendez vous avec
un psychiatre donc ce que vous pouvez
faire en attendant c'est allé voir un ou
une psychologue pour commencé à
défricher le terrain pour commencer à
avoir du soutien pour commencer un suivi
que vous pourrez éventuellement même
poursuivre après dernier truc ça peut
être
assez cher et être mal voire pas du tout
remboursés
donc ce que vous pouvez faire c'est
prendre rendez vous dans le centre
médico-psychologique près de chez vous
le cmp
c'est gratuit mais bon là encore ça peut
être long d'avoir un rendez vous bon
voilà là c'est vraiment juste la base de
la base encore une fois pour avoir un
truc un peu plus complet je pense que ça
mérite une vraie vidéo et je pense qu'on
va en reparler bientôt c'est possible
voilà on va arrêter là pour la première
partie je suis désolé j'ai bien
conscience qu'il ya plein de monde à qui
j'ai pas répondu mais encore une fois on
refera ce genre de vidéos de temps en
temps pour l'instant on passe à la faq
il a déjà fallu faire pas mal de choix
dans toutes les questions santé et
c'était vraiment la partie la plus
importante de la vidéo donc je vais
juste répondre à trois questions faq
celle qu'on va le plus posé ou celles
auxquelles j'avais pas encore répondu
alors moi ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est
si tu n'es pas docteur pourquoi tu en
sait autant sur le corps humain
tu sais tout sur tout et pourtant tu
n'es pas docteur j'aimerais aussi savoir
romain qui est il pour toi il est
toujours derrière la caméra
des fois on le voit des fois on le voit
pas mais en gros c'est ton techniciens
ou ton caméraman alors déjà assez gentil
mais non je ne sais pas tout surtout
d'ailleurs médecin ou pas personne ne
sait tout sur tout d'abord parce que la
santé c'est pas une science exacte
ça touche à l'humain il ya ce conseil à
ce qu'on sait pas il ya ce qu'on sait
pas encore faut savoir rester un petit
peu humble par rapport à tout ça et puis
ensuite les connaissances en matière de
santé comme dans plein de trucs
scientifique ça évolue
une étude vient contredire la précédente
une nouvelle découverte vient
bouleverser tout ce qu'on croyait savoir
donc voilà en plus il faut se tenir à
jour donc non je suis pas médecin je
suis infirmier c'est à dire que j'ai une
formation de base sur la santé mais
surtout sur les sujets que je traite à
chaque fois je fais des recherches pour
être le plus à jour possible parce que
croire qu'on a la science infuse et
qu'on sait tout sur tout c'est la pire
des choses
ensuite pour répondre à ta question sur
romain qui est romain mais je propose
qu'il réponde lui-même
il veut pas alors qui est romain et ben
tu as répondu un petit peu dans ta
question en fait
romain c'est le caméraman de détester le
preneur de son de dtc il s'occupe aussi
des lumières c'est le monteur de dtcc
celui qui s'occupe des effets spéciaux
c'est celui qui trouve des illustrations
relance et l'autre moitié de détecter
celles qu'on voit pas tout le temps à
l'image mais des fois quand même dont
les uns trop drôle etc
et puis romain c'est mon ami voilà parce
que j'aime travailler avec mes amis avec
mon ami en l'occurrence il a eu en train
de chialer
je me rappelle de l'époque au lycée où
je regardais tout le temps le rewind
gardez vous de bons souvenirs de cette
émission et de cette époque
alors c'est marrant parce qu'on me parle
beaucoup du rewind en ce moment sûrement
parce que ça vient de s'arrêter et que
ça faisait dix ans que ça durait alors
oui pour ceux qui connaissent pas le
wine c'était une émission quotidienne
une espèce de review sur les trucs
marrants d'internet et effectivement
c'est la première fois qu'on a travaillé
ensemble avec mon nom c'est pas un
épisode flashback genre trend et quand
c'est interdit depuis 1992 un tout le
monde trouve ça ringard ah bah non on
m'a j'aime bien quand même pas par le
gros blaireaux là je vous entends j'ai
mis les micros ah oui c'est vrai il y
avait ce petit jeune là comment il
s'appelait déjà cornélien ou je sais pas
quoi
bon bref pour répondre à ta question je
pense que je peux parler au nom de
romain et du bia et te dire oui c'était
génial on garde un très bon souvenir non
c'était de la merde
non il ne pense pas vraiment et du
savoir-faire son intérêt si je le pense
vraiment donc là il le pense pas non non
en fait c'était génial
avez vous déjà des projets planifiés
pour 2020 alors oui évidemment le
premier projet baas et de continuer dtc
ça va sans dire ça à l'air de rien comme
ça mais moi c'est quand même pas rien
ensuite il ya d'autres projets en
discussion ou en préparation sur youtube
ou ailleurs mais vous connaissez la
chanson tant que c'est parfait c'est
compliqué d'en parler pas forcément
parce que c'est interdit d'en parler
hein ça peut arriver mais ce n'est pas
toujours le cas
c'est surtout que c'est le genre de truc
qui peut tomber à l'eau d'un moment à
l'autre même si tu avais l'impression
que de cet effet que c'était bon je
parle d'expérience
donc pour pas annoncer des trucs qui
sortent jamais est passé pour un peigne
cul le mieux c'est d'annoncer les trucs
à coup sûr mais bon comme je suis pas
précisément ans terrorisée à l'idée de
passer pour un peigne cul etc en plus
j'en ai déjà parlé en 2020 normalement
je suis dans une série mi fiction mi
vulgarisation scientifique et ça devrait
être très cool et puis j'ai aussi un
souhait un voeu pour 2020 j'aimerais
bien jouer un petit peu plus la comédie
parce que j'aime bien ça voilà c'est
bien un projet vraiment mais c'est un
souhait un voeu donc appelé moi voilà
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui vous
pouvez continuer à m'envoyer vos
questions à question dtc @ gmail point
com
on se retrouve très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]